hello everybody and welcome back to
let's play dead space okay where are we
going this way okay just got the marker
- I restored power to the elevator take
it up to the hangar bay and get the
marker on the shuttle okay what do you
say ma'am now I am your loyal oh yeah
I'm just gonna run for it sorry well I
already went through this yeah you don't
need luck you will make up flash him
your boobs boobies all the monsters
there they're still kind of human so
they'll be distracted bit all right and
we're going to load it up into the
shuttle how are we gonna do that
oh no you tell me long boring elevator
of doom
oh yeah this is where I was I remember
opening these a long time ago that's
cool but first let me
another bathroom what is it with this
place in bathrooms at least is well
stocked with bathroom in business who's
puttin put this box here I certainly did
not I would not have missed out on boxes
actually maybe I would it because in the
beginning of this game I didn't even
know how to stomp so I wouldn't be
surprised if I didn't stomp a box hey
back here Wow look at this mom it feels
like a long time help here we go note up
the damage report baby Lulu oh oh no
look out buddy
aunt you're dead out you're dead ever
run away I'm so scared
yeah that's what happened alright C's
here whoa not again not again not again
all these guys haha hi
another black one
ah
step back
yes [ __ ] get back No
that's where you died oh you're not dead
man more than all right take it laughs
ha ha yeah not much of a challenge not
as scary as it was before because now I
have heavy ordnance and I know just
where to kill him did get me that
scratched me I'll come on why are these
still red I'm going to dr. Shah oh you
have to be careful now example now I saw
that you can't clip that door there but
it's okay oh do be aware the where there
where the other crook put your shovel
Yuri shovel down now the ospina moving
compose our response you'll have to shut
down gravity in the hangar bay and then
manually bring the marker directly
beneath the shuttle okay that sounds
cool and all but where where was our
first shuttle go where did it go it just
disappeared
oh well maybe it's gonna return as a
huge shuttle monster start was this door
locked before kaduk I don't know alright
shut off gravity sounds simple enough
okay I grab the control zero gravity
then I go but I just jumped down or
something wonk there we go
zoom through the air all fire sticks
yeah I got fire sticks again i'ma go oh
I love this way point if only cry here
at a waypoint system like this hey
Bartek what's that boom
oh come on you all from - but no boom
another one put that oh oh you up on the
wall
not today
that's if I just throw one of these
boxes I care
Oh what that boom miss I actually hit
him probably better damage how was that
come here wall where'd you go face I'm
bad at this game apparently need more
help again there's this marker Oh
goodies Hey
goodies I love me some goodies all right
there we go oh that thing that's which
to subtract so I can get it
I need to switch tracks why can't it
just be one track going straight
come on hurry up
get going okay so the yellow looks like
it goes in and then I
flipping around
has to be so violent and scary come on
now Oh get gone
the shuttle directly underneath
who's that hello I got a box for you huh
what's that Oh another one Sloane how
about water
I'm guessing
haha
Jacque y'all alright now flippy floppy
I gotta throw
and I'll flippy-floppy sniffing burgers
you at kinko's crazy
Oh
Wow someone's shooting at me oh hello
hello goodbye you thought about I'm
gonna you actually gonna stop one of you
to death
there we go well goodies ever gonna get
some goodies yeah yeah yeah all right we
reload my contact me push wall dug it
full ammo
alright now why couldn't I get it under
there not under there enough so needy
there we go alright um hello you can see
him still having trouble with these damn
loading to the souls
I think restore gravity to the room not
able to load the Walker then you got it
boss jump up on the screen I'm sure that
won't damage it sorry brick television
wonk
Arielle oh good you got it I haven't ate
- it's on board please come and join me
together and suck this quietly we could
end this nightmare finally yes please do
let's are we going down to the planet oh
I think we're going to the planet cool
beans
alright yes
oh we're going this way yeah I don't
care if you're crazy I'd go with anyone
yes finally he's right there can touch
him hi there's no time to waste
what what what John um what hang on I
got a med pack plug that up
what
Oh what is going on are you [ __ ] let me
go through with it I suppose I should
thank you for finding the marker dawn we
even managed without help in the USM
valor Thank You Melanie fine you're away
[ __ ] I knew it'd been looking for this
place for a long time see what kind of
nose was the government's mess to begin
with this whole planet is one big
experiment
well a few the marker this divine relic
made by man the reverse engineered a
couple of hundred years ago from the
real marker a true alien artifact
recovered on earth they dug it up
studied it and they made it their own
you know then they brought it to each of
seven and activated it and you've seen
the results oh the stuff of nightmares
oh yeah you'll see that I kissed you and
no one would have been the wiser but
then the cec blenders in it starts
tearing the planet apart yeah it's with
them
the experiment was still alive
I was right about the I've mine the
marker would contain it but that doesn't
matter how does it I have the marker and
this entire system can go to hell for
what it's worth you did a great job
Isaac thank you madam see you around
Oh F I need you to help me hey now I'm
I'm in the flight control room please
Isaac hurry please
okay that's like ten thousand degrees of
suspicious but I guess I got no choice
Yeah right she's a flight control room
yeah whatever okay I believe you
I believe you baby I'm gonna give me a
dead miss hug was that Wow
I'm not another one I got a contact beam
oh no bro stasis contact me contract
that do it that do it you son of a [ __ ]
let me dead I won't wait to come back
man your little baby here
oh come on why aren't you dead die Oh
there there oh come on you son of a
[ __ ]
Bom dammit
house always tell the contact be so
useless I shouldn't have bothered
go whoa hello Isaac what right is that
really you
oh holy crap I never thought we'd be
together again come um I'm so sorry I'm
so sorry for what I don't trust you hurt
you what did you do you need to get it
back now Isaac you can pilot the shell
remotely from here to make us holy make
us whole again no no I used to want to
before but I don't trust anyone
I don't trust you all I trust is this
platinum doodad or daimond okay
ah haha yeah look at this leave this I
just walked closing whoop crazy symbols
Oh Isaac is so gone off the deep end
whoosh whoosh whoosh whoosh yeah was
totally totally crazy shuttle recall
okay how are you doing haha you're
making a big mistake
oh yeah oh it's not over it's over when
a fad is over which is not over doesn't
get your wandering snarled G 0 9 repeat
shuttle has ejected escape pod oh it's
you oh she's got there she can't escape
her fate none of us can you're 10
degrees of psycho arja here comes I'll
report on the shuttle so we can fly down
to the colony
we're so close Isaac
now go get on the shuttle I'll meet you
there
no I don't think you will
cuz you're kind of crazy I'm gonna leave
without you baby sorry sorry this is
just a little too crazy I don't know how
you survive getting past that thing but
what what it was that beware don't look
back don't look back
okay
hey buddy dad buddy what's that warning
about don't look back if I let go back
it's you're gonna just like my face off
oh yeah me no likey all right let's see
what's up
Jesus she just creeps me out that whole
room discrete there's no way any of that
was Jim
no way no how
not good by going to the shuttle now ah
why don't come from what the hell
dammit I just love Mother's Day can we
get on the shuttle in the first place
how did she get on the shuttle how did
how did Nicole survive get it I'll get
it
Nicole's probably totally crazy in one
of them
don't trust do
don't trust Oh
you're doing the right thing Isaac uh
we're together now a little dirt on it
always should have been
I need you'd come back for me nothing
could stop us now
yeah don't trust you
chapter 11 completed with the crazy lady
next to me don't you crazy okay I'll
save here and that's all the time I got
for this episode so thank you so much
for joining me hope you enjoyed the
let's play so far and as always I will
see you in the next part I'm gonna get
out of here so it doesn't go through
here we'll see this in the next time
when I load up